the running rebels quickly rebuilding
their program
under the direction of kevin kruger and
of course many fans were excited to hear
that his dad
lon moving back here to las vegas as
well chris matthews has more on the
kruger's family plan to
revive the rebels kirsten kind of neat
to see two generations of krueger coach
as part of the
corn ferry tour pro am today at paiute
resort
kevin played as the new face of unlv
basketball on krueger
here just enjoying retirement the
kruegers were on the course today
enjoying the sunshine and family time
kevin was taking a break from busy
recruiting boy a big stretch there
and long just in town visiting before he
leaves to visit his other grandchildren
both father and son are excited about
the future of the runner-rebel program
kevin trying to fill the roster in our
first interview with lon since retiring
after 45 years the 68 year old says he's
excited to sit
in the stands and watch his son work
well one is just very supportive
as any fan is going to be again kevin
i've always talked basketball and we'll
always do that
but he's got a staff and they'll be
supportive and they'll help him and
they'll listen to each other so but barb
and i are excited about watching and
following and
promoting his program way we possibly
can and you don't think about
them ever growing to the age that
they're at you always think about them
when they're playing and when they're
in college or whatever and we stop and
think about it
and they're off to such any staff we're
off to such a great start great young
guys coming in
with the through the portal and that's
going to be a big part of the recruiting
process going forward and
love the group he's got coming in